[Música]
esta niña de 3 años acaba de llegar al
hospital su madre fue asesinada durante
el ataque a su población
mb la encontró en el suelo
había tantos cadáveres por todas partes
que era casi imposible pasar
la niña fue gravemente herida en la
mandíbula
primero dispararon con artillería pesada
luego llegaron numerosos soldados
asesinaron a todo el mundo sin
distinción sin importar la recoge el
bebé y voy a entrar en la vida como ella
cientos de víctimas civiles han llegado
al hospital central de mikel y durante
los últimos meses
vas mucho mejor ahora al principio de
las américas causadas por las
explosiones tras algunos días este
médico trabaja día y noche con recursos
limitados
es la primera vez en mi carrera que
estoy confrontando tales dificultades
pero tratamos de manejarlo con mi equipo
las dificultades son los cortes de
electricidad y la escasez de material
médico es mayor que el conflicto afecta
a todo tigre inicio de noviembre cuando
el frente de liberación del pueblo de
tigre atacó las posiciones de la
división militar federal las fuerzas
eritreas también ingresaron a la región
apoyando al ejército nacional numerosos
testigos afirman que militares y
milicias les dispararon a los civiles y
usaron la violación como arma de guerra
1 fue violada a finales de febrero por
soldados del ejército etíope mientras se
encontraba en su tienda acudió a estos
centros de salud en mikel
eran las 6 de la tarde estaba oscuro
debido a sus antorchas no pude ver sus
rostros me golpearon la cabeza y todo el
cuerpo con lo que encontraban eran unos
uno de los hombres puso su fusil en mi
nuca y caí al suelo y me violó
el centro recibió a más de 130 víctimas
desde el inicio del conflicto pueden
declarar y recibir ayuda médica
que precise el esposo de mulos viene con
frecuencia a recibir noticias ahora se
esconde en un refugio especializado por
miedo a represalias él vive en una
escuela transformada en campo de fortuna
las condiciones sanitarias son precarias
esta es el agua que bebemos tal como
usted lo puede ver este recipiente de
esta solución
a través de tigre más de medio millón de
personas huyeron
en mikel en la capital regional miles de
refugiados lo han abandonado todo de la
noche a la mañana
aquí no hay suficiente agua ni comida o
ropa no recibimos ayuda del gobierno de
los salones de clases han sido
transformados en dormitorios cada uno ha
vivido el horror de los combates
este hombre afirma que soldados eritreos
lo encerraron en una iglesia
he vivido bajo cuatro gobiernos desde el
s la cia hasta hoy antes cuando había
combates a los campesinos les pedía que
se fueran pero hoy en día se en el
masacre y las iglesias ya no son
santuarios los civiles son sacados y
asesinados como este padre numerosos
sobrevivientes denuncian masacres y
acusan a los soldados eritreos
organizaciones de derechos humanos
también le han llamado la atención a
asmara pero el presidente temporal de
tigre asegura que el tlf es el
responsable de esta inserción la ilusión
y la confusión imperan entre el pueblo
de segre debido a todas estas falsas
informaciones en realidad es culpa del
frente de liberación del pueblo de tigre
que si la paz ha sido perturbado es el
tps efe el que atacó a nuestros
militares etíopes está a cargo de
proteger al pueblo nosotros la
administración temporal entre nuestro
trabajo es salvar la vida de la gente y
restaurar la seguridad y estabilidad
christensen nos reunimos con 16 en su
pueblo a 60 kilómetros al norte de
meckel y los habitantes aseguran que más
de 150 personas fue
asesinadas por los miembros del ejército
eritreo durante una fiesta religiosa
cuando escuchamos los primeros disparos
huimos por el costado del río y los
disparos continuaron muy lejos
ingresamos a una mujer con oro muchos
soldados disparaban y cuando vieron que
nadie respondía los soldados ingresaron
a esta casa y asesinaron a dos personas
como está aquí podemos hacer
mi hermano mis primos sus padres le
explicaron a los militares por favor en
nombre de la virgen sólo vinieron para
la celebración y los militares les
dijeron a los padres que se fueran pero
suplicando y mi hermano y dos primos
fueron asesinados frente a sus padres de
paulette
cientos de personas se encontraban en la
iglesia más grande gland para la misa
los que pudieron esconderse se salvaron
pero aquí todo el mundo perdió
familiares
esto es muy triste todo lo que
fallecieron eran como mi familia este
hombre su hermana fue asesinada y él su
hermano él también sus hermanos este sus
padres todas estas personas están en
duelo no solo ellos todos los habitantes
de tigre
[Música]
los sobrevivientes afirman que hay
muchas fosas comunes en su pueblo un
grupo dice haber sido forzado a cavar
las tumbas por los soldados eritreos los
soldados nos dieron la orden de
enterrarlos éramos seis y si veías el
cadáver de un miembro de tu familia no
podías llorar nos dijeron si uno de
ustedes llora o si desplazan el cuerpo
al cementerio de la iglesia los asesinar
hemos también microbio alguno tiempo
tras haberlo negado durante mucho tiempo
el primer ministro había cmet reconoció
finalmente la presencia de tropas
eritreas en tigre el 23 de marzo dice
que los responsables de las atrocidades
serán castigados pero a pesar de estas
promesas las violencias contra civiles
continúan en las zonas rurales donde hay
miles que siguen en medio de los
combates